[Applaudissements]
alors boissons coup de coeur votre coup
de coeur c'est pour la chaîne des 8 eh
bien on a un nouveau directeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
duo
s'il vous plaît merci xavier d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui directeur général de
10,8 pouvait remarquer que le directeur
général de débuter dans la même classe
que baptiste ambitions juste un an
d'écart ce qu'il a redoublé
mais voilà il y là le gars a juste 16
ans aulas ça doit bien xavier ça va être
super content et ya une fête ses 5
alors il avoir une fiesta pour vous mais
à la tortue on va faire des sardines 1
pour fêter bien sûr l'avènement de
xavier gandon l'hégémonie doxa des gants
dont autour de dénis puisque maintenant
rien ne passe sans que xavier gandon
valide servir à brushing de beinheim ya
quelques à 4,11 tac tac directeur
général zia brushing à 2,50
on y va à sa part
[Applaudissements]
là ça c'est un cadeau cachemire ça un
cadeau il m'était pas des caisses mire
avant avant c'était 10% élasthanne 15
ans en fibre de verre
[Applaudissements]
bon
monza des eaux on est très heureux pongo
tout cas est une méritons xavier c'est
vrai qu'on se tutoie sais c'est une
bombe de patron je peux le faire un
bisou à les jeta coaching à les attend à
matin sur l'a4 est chez vous le suivant
nous ont pas trop attention sa ville
chan 2011
c'est au fond
et alors là eh ben voilà c'est aussi tu
vois dans les autres chaînes où je suis
passé il y avait pas de nominations
comme c'est à l'antenne ses salariés
[Applaudissements]